So I want to talk about some more attributes
of this structure.
Okay, now, broadly speaking what we’re going
to say is that a motivation sets up one of
these frameworks.
I’m going to call this framework a story.
Now there’s lots of things you could call
it.
You could call it an expectancy model, you
could call it a game; I’m going to call
it a story and we’re going to say well what
you do is you have a life story and your life
story is composed of nested sub-stories.
You could also think of it as a personality,
but a story is like a personality in action.
So, we’ll just stick with story.
The story has a starting place, that’s where
you are, and the story has an endpoint, that’s
where you’re going.
And you’re always in one of those stories,
or you’re asleep.
So, you’re either pursuing something in
the real world that is of value, that’s
directly motivated, or you’re pursuing another
situation where the reason you’re pursing
it is because it fulfills a bunch of motivational
states now and into the future.
So that ‘s what you’re doing when you
pursue, say a career.
And, if you’re not doing that, then your
mind is wandering and what it’s doing is
it’s wandering through the space of hypothetical
worlds where you can play hypothetical roles.
And if you’re not doing that then you’re
asleep.
So you’re in one of these all the time.
Now they shift, and that’s one of the things
that’s quite interesting about them.
The shift can take place on all sorts of levels.
You can differently conceptualize the way,
where you are.
You can differently conceptualize where you’re
going, and you can differently conceptualize
how you’re going to get there.
Now, I won’t go into that for the moment.
So let’s say you’re going from point A
to point B. At the highest level of resolution
that means that you’re acting.
And then other things that happen is not only
are you acting, you’re configuring your
perceptions.
We already talked a little bit about this.
You know what you should highlight, what you
should bring your high resolution thinking
to bear on, and you know what you should ignore.
And what you should ignore is those things
that are likely to remain constant as you
pursue the set of transformations, or that
aren’t going to interfere with what you’re
doing.
And so you just have to concentrate, especially
if you set your environment up properly, and
that’s another thing.
Part of the way that people deal with the
complexity of the world is by just not having
it around.
You know so for example, even if you look
in this room, a lot of things are radically
simplified so that you don’t get overwhelmed.
“How many of you have computers here?
Okay, now what does your computer look like?
Keyboard?
Screen?
What about the rest of it?
Flat?
Shiny?
Aluminum?
Why?”
Because you want to act like that’s one
thing.
You don’t want to act like it’s – “how
many transistors are on a chip now?
Like a billion or more?”
A lot, and they’re down to molecular size
those things.
They’re so small now, this is really funny,
they’re so small now that – so imagine
electrons running along a wire.
Now the weird thing about an electron is it
might be there and it might be somewhere else.
So it’s got this vague, non-locality about
it.
You know like maybe it’s supposed to be
there but it’s actually over there; and
would happen now and then.
But the wires are so damn thin now that there’s
some good probability that the electron will
be outside the wire, and that causes short-circuits.
So, that’s quite, well you’ve got quantum
level complexity mucking up your circuitry
in your computer.
But look, the computer is designed this way,
right?
It’s designed so you can ignore it.
The outside of it is a flat shell.
It’s a low-resolution image.
And, not the keyboard because you have to
move it, not the screen and everything else
is flat.
The designer, the primate designer of this
computer does not want your poor primate brain
to be overwhelmed by the fact that this thing
is incomprehensibly complex.
Cars are the same they have that nice shiny
shell on them and so that you can just sort
of low resolution it and that’s good enough.
The walls painted roughly the same color,
we’re doing a lot things around us to reduce
the sensory lobe.
Plus, there are people beadling away in the
background like mad making sure the lights
stay on and making sure the heat stays on,
you know making sure you have air in here.
The place isn’t burning down, there aren’t
crazy people wandering around in here with
shotguns and rifles.
There’s a lot going on so that you can sit
here and pretend that you know enough to stay
alive.
So, we’re also removing a tremendous amount
of complexity as a consequence of social cooperation.
Okay, so these are all parts of the way that
you simplify the world.
You’re in a radical simplification structure
that’s the external society.
Then within that there’s only certain things
you want, and then within that there’s only
certain things you can detect, and then within
that there’s only certain features that
pop out as necessary to contemplate in the
realm that you’re dealing with.
Now, one thing you might ask is well, “what
time span are you usually dealing with?”
You know cause what the world’s made of
depends on the time span; and that’s a tough
one.
We know that it’s more than 1/10th of a
second.
But you can think years into the future, right?
So I might say well, “why are you going
to university?”
Or I might say, “what are you doing right
now?”
And then the answer would be, well I’m sitting
in class.
And then the question would be, “well why
are you sitting in class?”
And the answer to that would be well because
I want to take this course.
“And why?”
Well it’s because I want to get my degree.
“Why?”
Well, because I want to be prepared for a
career and, you know, a productive and high
quality life when I get out.
Well, “why?”
Well you know you can keep saying why, pretty
much indefinitely and as you answer you go
farther and farther out in time scales.
Now, it’s a tricky thing because one of
the things I might tell you, and this is a
very complex cognitive problems is, “well
where should you stop?”
So for example, I could say, “do you want
100 dollars now or do you want 50 000 years
in 75 years?”
You’re going to think, “well I’ll probably
take the 100 dollars now.”
“Well how about in 200 years?”
It’s like, well I’m not going to be there
I’ll take the 100 bucks now.
So obviously thinking out 200 years is not
that helpful.
Now you might think well no, you should calculate
the effects of your actions on the vastest
time span possible and include the largest
number of people, if you’re really going
to equilibrate it.
But the problem is you can’t do the computations.
Because you get, you get this called combinatorial
explosion happening, which is that, it’s
like a chessboard.
You make one move, okay fine.
But then you could make four and with each
of those you could make four more and then
with each of those you could make four more
and soon if you’re looking twenty moves
ahead, it’s like there’s so many moves
that the other person could possibly make,
that looking that far ahead is pointless.
You can’t do the computations.
And so, we don’t know how far you should
look into the future, it depends on how stable
your environment is.
But, one month seems okay, a year, yeah, three
to five years, that’s what Ill have you
do when I have you do the future-authoring
program.
“Twenty years?”
Hmm, probably not.
And the reason for that is the margin of error
in your prediction grows so large that your
prediction isn’t worth anything, and you
can really see how that’s the case now,
cause like, “what’s it going to be like
in twenty years?”
When I was a kid I used to read science fiction.
It was like, plausible accounts of the potential
future.
It’s like, now, who knows?
Anything could happen.
You know you could be three quarters robot
in twenty years.
You could have a lifespan of ten thousand
years.
I mean, we just do not know.
We could be living in caves again with everything
in ruins.
We don’t have a clue what’s going to happen.
So twenty-year span, I would say, get friendly
with computers.
So twenty-year span is too long.
So, okay, anyways what I ‘m pointing out
is that you have to calculate, you have to
calculate what you’re doing in across multiple
spans of time, and in the combination, and
in combination with many many people.
And that makes things very complex.
But that’s how you’re building the structures
that you live within.
Alright, so back to this.
You’re at point A you’re going to point
B. So, you are somewhere.
Now, that’s interesting.
You are somewhere.
Now generally what people think about when
they think about being somewhere is that they’re
in a place.
But you’re not just in a place.
You’re in a place at a time.
And I really want to stress that because we
know that the universe, we know that the environment
is four-dimensional, not three-dimensional.
That’s important because you could be in
the same place, and in the next second you’re
still where you were but you’re in a completely
different place.
So for example, if someone walked in here
with a pistol, this would not be the same
place.
Okay, so there’s a reason I’m telling
you that.
And then, there’s the future, and that’s
also a place in time and a place in space.
Okay, now you’re getting from point to the
other, and you’re going to do that by implementing
certain behaviors.
Now you might say, what can happen while your
doing that?
Well here’s three things that can happen.
The thing you want, that can happen.
Something you don’t want, but that you understand,
and something you don’t understand at all,
something completely beyond your comprehension.
And that would generally be a traumatizing
event of some sort.
So, you can either know what’s going to
happen.
Or you cannot know and still be able to cope
with it, or you can not know and not cope
with it.
Of the negative ones they correspond to that
hierarchy, right?
If it’s a little thing that you don’t
understand you just modify a little behavior.
If it’s a big thing that you don’t understand,
well then what?
Well then everything falls apart.
Don’t know where you are, don’t know where
you’re going, and all the behaviors you
have are not helpful.
And that’s when your world falls apart.
So, generally that doesn’t happen.
So, let’s say I set my target on the door.
I’m going to walk to the door.
So here’s what happens.
Instantly, I’m slightly, I have slight negative
emotion about the fact that any of blank issue
in the way people exist.
Because what my brain is doing is reconfiguring
the world, to chart a straight path and anything
that’s in the way is going to make me uneasy-
frustrated, disappointed, anxious.
And you can think about this when you do house
design, by the way.
So, when you’re setting up a room, what
you want to do is figure out what the room
is for.
Then you want to clear the paths for that.
Because then when you walk into the room,
the room will say, “Welcome!
You can do the things you want to do here,
easily.”
And if you don’t do that, it’s all cluttered
up.
It’s like, there’s no difference between
that and being confused mentally.
It’s exactly the same thing.
So, okay, so let’s say I now stand up and
that works and then I walk that way, and that
way and that way.
I keep my eyes on the door, and I’m getting
towards the door.
Well I’m moderately positive about that,
because I’m getting where I’m going, but
I’m also moderately positive about it because
the fact that I’m getting where I’m going
validates my whole theory.
So one of the things that the behaviorists
didn’t get right when they were thinking
about punishment - If an animal lays out a
behavior and you punish it, it’ll stop manifesting
that behavior.
But that isn’t all that happens.
You think about punishing a human being.
They stop manifesting the behavior, but the
behavior isn’t the whole damn thing.
The thing you’re in is this, it’s the
whole thing.
It’s the conception of where they are, it’s
the conception of where they’re going, and
it’s all the behaviors they might need to
get there.
So, you know, maybe they’ll try to circumvent
the punishment, walk around it.
Maybe they’ll try a few more behaviors,
but what happens, you know, so I’m tied
by a chain and I don’t know it, I’m tied
by a chain to the wall.
I start walking that way and I figure out
that I’m chained.
Well, so much for that stupid theory, I’m
not getting to the door.
I’m going to let that view of the world
disintegrate, I’m going to be very upset
about that, and then I have to come up with
another one, which might be, “well how do
I get rid of the chain?”
So when you fail, two things happen.
The behavior that you’re manifesting doesn’t
work, that’s the behaviorist routine.
But it’s worse than that because the whole
little personality that you’re using to
construe the world falls apart.
And the more important the thing is that has
fallen apart, the more of a catastrophe it’s
going to be for you.
So let’s say you’re going to medical school,
that’s what you want to do.
Alright, so, you’re taking the course to
write the exam to pass the course with an
A to apply to medical school to get into medical
school to be a doctor.
You fail the test, “what just happened?”
“ Well, did your whole future fall apart?”
“Or did you just fail the test?”
Who knows, right?
Maybe you’re whole future just fell apart,
it’s like, now you have a GPA of 3.3, like
No, you have to go to the Caribbean to a private
medical school.
You’re not going to get in anywhere in Canada
or the United States, it’s like, okay, “is
your life over?”
“Do you jump off a bridge?”
Well sometimes people do.
And it’s because the little sub-personality
that they created which is the “me that
will be a doctor”, it’s one of these things
the little story, it’s so integral to their
entire identity, that when it collapses they’re
done.
And people get suicidal when that sort of
thing happens.
Okay, so well, “what are you supposed to
do when that happens?”
Well, that’s something that we’ll talk
about.
You know, from the perspective of mental hygiene,
one of the things I would recommend is that
when things go wrong for you, you start at
the highest level of resolution in your hierarchy
and work upward.
You don’t say, “well God, now everything’s
over!”
You know, you might say, “okay, what can
I do to ensure that I do better on the next
test?”
So, then you could analyze your subroutines,
your micro-subroutines, like how much do you
study a day?
Well, sometimes people will tell me “I study
six hours a day.”
It’s like, no you don’t.
You sit in front of what you’re supposed
to be doing for six hours a day, but if you
actually study for more than three I would
be shocked.
Cause I’ve met almost no one in my entire
life, who can sustain high-level concentration
for more than 3 hours, for more than 6 days
a week for more than a year.
You’ll just burn yourself to a crisp.
So no, you’re deluding to yourself into
thinking that you’re studying six hours
a day.
You’d be way better off to cut it down to
two and a half and actually do it.
There’s micro-routine analysis that you
can do.
So that might be helpful, then you can implement
that and run it, that’s what you’d do
if you’re a behavioral psychologist.
Someone comes and says, “my life’s over”
and you say, “well let’s go through the
micro-routines.”
Well, they say, “well what do you mean?
Well they say, “I can’t be a doctor.”
Well, okay.
“Could you be a nurse?
Would that work?
Could you be a medical technician?”
You know, could you be a social worker?
Etc, like okay so your domain is helpful medical
type of person.
Well one element of that is doctor, but it
doesn’t exhaust the entire realm of possibilities.
So I’d say flex up a bit!
You know, it’s not the only path.
And so that would be a more high-level adjustment,
that’d be a more cognitive adjustment.
If you’re in Cognitive Behavioral Therapy,
it’s like, let’s check out your subroutines,
make you more effective at studying, but you
know, let’s loosen up your top-level abstractions.
You should be a good person, let’s say.
Whatever you decide that means.
One element of that is, be productively employed
in a way that doesn’t make you bitter and
nasty.
Okay, doctor might be one way of solving that,
although I wouldn’t be so sure of that.
But it’s not the only way of solving it.
So, alright, you go from point A to B. You
go from point A to point B, and things can
happen along the way.
Things you like – positive emotion, you’re
getting there, plus you’re right.
Things that produce negative emotion – you’re
not getting there, okay.
You can either solve them easily, with small
behavioral adjustment, or you have to go up
the hierarchy of value and adjust it with
the least possible damage, generally speaking-
because that’s another rule of thumb in
therapy.
I can’t be a doctor so I’m going to be
an engineer.
Well, no.
You’ve got three years behind you, don’t
just throw it away, use what you’ve got
and make a minor course deviation, if you
can do it.
And you know we can talk about broader scale
transformations, but they’re costly.
But you know stick as close to the path as
you can, while altering it enough so that
you can proceed to your final goal.
And so, well I think this is where we’ll
stop today, that leads us to the next part
of the story.
So, here’s the kind of story that someone
can tell.
I was at point A and I went to point B and
here’s how I did it.
And you’re pretty happy about that story.
Maybe you go on Youtube and, I found this
a year ago, I had this old car wanted to put
a stereo in it and so I typed in, “how to
put a stereo in an x old car” and there’s
a helpful retired southern guy who, you know,
made a Youtube video out of it.
I was interested in his little story, and
he didn’t have a car stereo in his car and
he wanted one, I didn’t have a car stereo
in my car and I wanted one.
So his little story about how to do that was
very interesting to me.
So I ran the little tape and I did it.
Great, not particularly transformational,
but good enough.
I got some information.
Alright, so that’s an alright story and
you’re running around all of the time interfacing
with other people and you’re telling them
you’re little story and they’re telling
you their little story.
But you know so that’s one thing that interests
people – how to do something successfully.
But a lot of what people talk about is something
different.
Which is, I was trying to get from point A
to B and it didn’t work and now I’m at
a place where it didn’t work.
And so it’s a problem, right?
The world’s opened up around me, I don’t
know what to do.
And the reason you talk to people about that,
is because they have brains.
And so do you.
And you might as well have two brains working
if you can and if you’re reciprocal, you
know, you’re in trouble you come to me,
and we talk it out, and maybe I can help.
And then because we’re playing a interitive
game, now you owe me a favor.
Now, you know, I’m not going to be too restrictive
about that, but you know, socially intelligent
people are reciprocal.
Ben Franklin once said, you’re new in a
neighborhood what should you do to get integrated?
He said, ask a neighbor for a favor.
A small favor – don’t ask will you build
me a new house?
It’s like, no that’s not going to work.
But, “my dog’s on the front lawn would
you watch him for 2 minutes while I run to
the corner store?”
It’s like, okay they can do that.
Well why would you do that?
Well it opens up the possibility of a reciprocal
exchange.
It’s very very smart, cause now they can
ask you for a favor.
So you get the trade thing going.
People who are highly social are really good
at identifying and maintaining reciprocal
obligations.
So, we use each other as problem solving resources.
And a lot of our communication is exactly
that.
And so basically the story you’re telling
isn’t I was at point A and I went to point
B and everything worked.
The story is this instead.
It’s half of this.
I was at point A (that’s the top left hand
corner), I was at point A and I was going
to point B but something didn’t work.
And then things collapsed, you know, to a
greater or lesser extent, depending on the
severity of the event, and the closeness of
your friendships that you’re telling the
story, you’re not going to tell catastrophic
stories to someone on a bus that you just
sat down beside, unless you have a mental
illness.
Well, really it’s the truth.
Sometimes you sit down on a bus, and someone
who has a mental illness will come and sit
beside you and they will immediately tell
you horrible things about their life.
And the reason for that is, they have to.
They don’t have anyone to talk to, they
can’t sort out their brains.
They’re so desperate, they’re so ruined,
they’re in chaos.
They’re so ruined, that the proclivity to
proclaim the chaos absolutely overwhelms them.
And you just can’t deal with someone like
that most of the time because the magnitude
of the problem they’re facing you with is
way beyond your capacity to solve, so it’s
just awkward.
It’s not good.
Anyways, you say, I was going from point A
to point B, didn’t work!
Now I don’t know where I am, I don’t know
where I’m going and I’m lost.
And you say, “in my experience when I was
in a situation like this, I did this, I did
this and I know someone else in that situation
who did this maybe you could try those.”
Or maybe you just shut up, and you let the
person talk!
And that’s often extremely useful.
And the reason you do that is because they’re
thinking.
Because people think they think, but they
don’t.
they talk.
Thinking is hard.
Right, it’s a very complex abstract, cognitive
operation.
And I don’t think that they’re many more
people who can think, than there are people
who can really read.
And that’s probably 2-5% of the population
at most.
And so most of the way that people deal with
that is that they talk.
And that’s their thinking, and so they have
some ideas about what might be going on, but
they’re mixed and muddy, so they’re basically
throwing out these ideas, “did this happen?
Is he like this?
Is she like that?
Did I do this?”
And then they watch you, and if you’re nodding
about one then they think, oh well, you know,
that seems plausible, and they you lay out
another, and they don’t even notice and
then you think well that’s off the table,
I didn’t think that was a very good idea,
but now I’ve got some social validation,
and soon they talk it out, and instead of
having sixty vaguely defined problems, now
they have five very tightly defined problems.
They’re feeling a lot better about that,
right, because it’s five snakes instead
of sixty.
And maybe they can deal with five snakes.
So you’ve already helped them a whole bunch
just by listening.
You know, and then maybe you can be an active
listener, they lay out their story and you
say, well you said something here that doesn’t
make any sense with this thing that you said.
So you know, how would you reconcile those?
You know, it’s this dialectical process
and so the person collapses into chaos, and
they come and tell you about it and you rescue
them if you can out of the chaos and then
they pop back up the other side.
Clinical practice is actually a formalized
version of an ideal relationship.
So you think, “what’s an ideal relationship?”
Well, I would say that an ideal relationship
is where both of you are trying to get better
than you are and you’re helping each other
do it.
It’s something like that.
You know if I have a good relationship with
you I would rather that you’re the best
you, you can be.
And I would assume that you would also like
that for me.
I mean things interfere with that because
you might say, well if given how horrible
I am, if my partner all of a sudden got a
clue, they’d leave, so I’d better interfere
with that as much as I possibly can.
People do that all the time.
You know one of the things they’ll do is
make sure their partner isn’t too attractive.
It’s like, if you’re so attractive, why
are you with someone like me?
It’s like, I’ll criticize you when you
look attractive and that’ll fix that.
So, and people do that sort of thing all the
time.
This is the revolutionary story.
This is the real story people tell.
I was here and I got bloody-well knocked off
my perch and then for a while things were
not good.
And then you know I reconfigured myself, I
learned some things, I did some exploration,
I made some changes, and poof!
Off the other side I come.
And I’m a better person for it.
And if you listen to the way people talk about
their pasts, especially with regards to traumatic
events, they’ll often tell you that.
They’ll say, well you know in retrospect
that was the best thing that ever happened
to me.
It’s like, those are the people who come
out the other side I’ll tell you.
Lots of people, they fall into the belly of
the beast and they never come out.
You see that fairy tales some times.
So there will be a hero, and he’ll conquer
some sort of dragon or some sort of monster
and when he cuts it open and a bunch of people
come out.
It’s like, yeah!
They’re the ones that got swallowed by the
thing.
And it isn’t until that person comes along
that solves the problem that all those other
people get to come out.
So, that’s a revolutionary story.
It’s the archetypal revolutionary story.
And it’s the story of human progress.
Socially, politically, economically, psychologically.
And you see that reflected, for example, one
of the things I could tell you about Christianity
is that it’s a revolutionary narrative.
At the beginning, so if you look at the Bible,
structured like a piece of literature, at
the beginning there’s a fall, everyone was
doing fine and then they wake up and they
find out that the bottom is dropped out.
And then the whole rest of this book is about,
okay, how do you get back up?
Actually it is in this, I’ll tell you, partly
what the Bible is, is the attempt by, broadly
speaking Western civilization, so that would
be all the way from the Middle East, to the
west - it’s the West’s attempt to figure
out what’s wrong with life and how to fix
it.
And it’s the collaboration of thousands
of people over thousands of years, of course
you can say that about any ancient moral tradition.
So, the question is, “well is there an answer
to that question?”
Well that’s one of the next things we’re
going to try to figure out.
Well let’s say you’re driving down the
401.
Your car breaks down.
You’re off by the side of the road, maybe
it’s snowing, it’s like “how bad is
that?”
Well you don’t know.
Maybe someone slides on the snow and runs
over you, you’re dead, it’s really bad.
So you’re freaking out, maybe your phone
isn’t working so you check your phone, that’s
not working, it’s like all of a sudden things
have gotten worse.
So this person drives up behind you and they
stop.
You’re a bit nervous about them because
what are they up to?
And they come up, they open the hood and they
say, “well this thing’s loose.”
And they put it in there.
It’s like, are you happy?
Well, yes, because what’s happened to you
is magic.
First of all you’re not in a car, soon as
it stops working by the way.
It’s only a car when it’s working.
When it’s not working it’s a bag of snakes,
right?
It’s like, uh oh, this car isn’t working.
“What could be wrong with it?”
OH!
It’s an infinite number of things, none
of which I understand!
And those things are all attached to people
who are going to fix the car.
“Can I trust them?
Do I even know who they are?
Are they going to empty my wallet?
Do I need to have a new car?”
So you don’t know, and then well your day
is gone.
So all of a sudden, what happens is you’re
environment complexifies radically.
And you get all nervous because there’s
a lot of paths in there that you might have
to traverse to get back to where you’re
going.
Someone comes along and goes, tap!
It’s like you’re happy, and all the complexities
collapsed.
In one path it went poof, your story is now
implementable again.
And you’ll pay people for that.
You do it all the time.
It’s like, you got a problem, you take it
to an expert.
They say, it’ll take you an infinite amount
of time to traverse all these possible paths
so you’re basically screwed, but if you
give me a hundred dollars I can tell you how
to do it in five minutes.
You think, “yes!
That’s worth it!”
So of course it’s efficient, that’s why
we trade.
It’s exactly why we trade.
Things are going to go wrong with you that
I could help, and vice versa, what a deal!
That’s partly why we’re social and why
we maintain it.
Like as a collective, we’re way more intelligent
than we would be if we were one person.
So, alright, that’s a revolutionary story.
That’s a collapse into the underworld, and
a rebirth.
And so as soon as you know that it’s so
cool to know that because now, whenever you
read a classic story of any sort you can think
oh that’s a voyage to the underworld!
I’ve been there, and you have!
everyone’s been there, the underworld is
where that’s chaos it’s chaos, it’s
where you go when your life falls apart.
It has a structure.
And what’s even cooler about that is, once
you know this, there’s actually guides through
it.
It’s like, okay, your world fell apart.
“What do you do about it?”
Dying of stress is a bad idea.
You don’t have to do that.
So I was talking to one of the students during
the break.
We were talking about character, and I said,
well, the best thing you can do is build your
character.
Here’s a test of character.
A family member is dying, okay, are you useful
or useless?
That’s the first question.
And then a deeper question is, do you make
it as good as it can be?
Which isn’t going to be that good by the
way, or do you turn it into hell?
Because you can, and lots of people do.
So one of the tests of character is - okay,
there’s a crisis.
Like really!
“How are you going to respond?
Are you going to be helpful?
Or are you going to be useless?”
Or ever worse, are you going to make it worse?
I would say, helpful, and the thing that’s
so cool about human beings is that we can
do that.
People are so tough it’s insane; as long
as they put themselves in the position.
My sister-in-law works as a palliative care
nurse.
It’s like all she does is work with people
who are going to die in two weeks.
She’s a happy person, partly because she
goes home and thinks, hey this isn’t a palliative
care ward!
Well really man!
Things can be worse.
And she knows that and she’s reminded of
it every day.
That’s a person who does not take things
for granted.